bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors que retenez
vous de cette rencontre entre les deux
hommes bon on me l'ont dit tous les deux
et ils ont juste des reprises et pour
l'instant le la glace de la méfiance est
maintenant c'est tellement que dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines niveau on pouvoir discuter
concrètement de sécu promettre dans ce
qu'ils appellent à dos et que le
président à son hôte à l'appel et le le
dialogue sincère et franc entre les deux
hommes entre temps le président henri
konan-bédié pourrait poser un certain
nombre de préalables au dialogue à la
discussion c'est à dire la libération
des différents l'île de la coalition de
l'opposition qui ont été entreprises qui
ont été arrêtés emprisonnés
il s'agit de pascal affi n'guessan de
professeur maurice kakou guikahué et
l'arrestation de hélas à l'arrêt de
toute poursuite judiciaire
donc voilà c'est qu'il faut retenir
c'est que pour l'instant ça a été on
pourra dire la prise de contact on
appelait ça à l'étal à l'époque j'étais
à l'étape du symbole et certainement les
prochains jours la prochaine semaine il
y aura exactement c'est qui et c'est qui
on continue bien ce qui sera mis dans
dans ce dialogue franc et sincère entre
l'opposition le président à son hôte a
alors alliés puis rivaux est ce que les
deux hommes pourrait de nouveau finir
par s'entendre au point de cohabiter
peut-être au sein du futur gouvernement
pour l'instant je pense que le chef de
l'état
prisa ouattara joue aidant dans sa ligne
depuis le début le départ pour lui
l'opposition demandait le dialogue avant
les élections lui disaient les élections
d'abord parce que c'est la date
constitutionnelle et le dialogue après
je crois qu'il est dans son agenda
pour lui le dialogue va se faire le
débat va se faire mais poussée qui est
de du retour de l'amour de l'amitié
entre les deux hommes personnellement je
n'ai jamais jugé que ces deux hommes
s'appréciaient d'une certaine façon mais
pour certain nombre d'intérêts
politiques et c'est un nombre de poisons
de raison les deux hommes se sont alliés
je crois à partir de demain à partir de
2005 se sont retrouvés en 2010 lors des
élections contre la candidature de
laurent gbagbo est aujourd'hui je pense
que le président henri konan bédié le
pdci et l'opposition ont une chose
claire l'en-tête ne sont pas d'accord
avec troisième mandat du président
alassane ouattara que juge
inconstitutionnel et illégal
je pense que ce sera l'un des points
d'achoppement ou de crises et des
crispations lors des débats qu'ils ont
est ce que cette élection est en train
de faire basculer le pays
pour l'instant là quand tu vois à vis
des temps difficiles pour l'instant la
côte d'ivoire vit des temps difficiles
depuis la déclaration du président
ouattara de sa candidature pour ce
troisième mandat il ya eu beaucoup de
morts c'est un pas de deux près d'une
centaine de morts c'est vrai qu'au
niveau du chiffre des morts des blessés
des dégâts matériels
ça chipote mais c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
situation en côte d'ivoire est tendue la
situation est tendue cela ne figure de
lendemains pas du tour il serait
intéressant comme beaucoup
d'observateurs de la vie publique
on l'observé long long long conseiller
et ont su gérer ou faut que les acteurs
de la vie politique ivoirienne s'asseye
et qu'ils discutent le véritablement et
sincèrement de ces qui les divisent de
ce qui me pose problème en côte d'ivoire
pour qu'ils puissent art pour que la
situation puisse être dès qu'ils peuvent
plus se détendre mais
répond à espérer à regarder les choses
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de craintes
beaucoup de craintes mais si le dialogue
commence sincère et franc nous pensent
que les choses pourront s'est décantée
sinon aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons
reçus après nous avoir eu à ce que nous
avons eu hier on dirait que c'était
tango d'hypocrite
alors donc dialogue en tout cas première
étape entre l'asean ouattara et henri
konan bédié est ce que monsieur bédié
assez de pouvoir pour convaincre toute
l'opposition d'abandonner son projet de
conseil national de transition et de
reconnaître l'élection
pour l'instant je ne pense pas que
président pour le faut car le conseil
national de transition
il se prononce pour ce week-end se
présente lui du point de vue de haut
niveau du pays si le président bédié
parle très souvent nos deux attaquants
présents du tube précis le vocable cnt
est de moins en moins utilisé mais je
pense que le fond du problème irait
c'est à dire les différentes
revendications est la principale c'est
vous la non-reconnaissance du troisième
mandat du président alassane ouattara
je pense que sur le fond ils vont ils
voir et c'est là dessus puisque le
présent henri konan bédié a laissé
entendre clairement que pour l'instant
la situation l'espagne et les prochains
jours les prochaines semaines
permettront nous comprendre et 2 dudit
véritablement ce qui a changé c'est
qu'il évolue mais je pense que le
président bédié ne change pas les fusils
d'épaulé
il pose un préalable important la
libération des camarades de lutte ici
permet d expression et l'arrêt de toutes
les poursuites judiciaires
et il faut la comprendre aussi qu'il a
c'est ce qui aurait chuté de cette
rencontre qui demandent le retour et
l'inclusion dans le débat ben c'est un
nom de soutien des partisans pro gbagbo
est envisagée même le peloton du
président laurent gbagbo lui même